earlier today I had the opportunity to
interview on stage Google senior vice
president sundar Pichai we talked about
a lot of these issues one thing that
came up was the prospect that Google
would operate its own wireless network
are called an MVNO take a listen to what
he had to say there have been reports in
the press that Google is talking to
wireless carriers about a Google branded
network also called an mvno what can you
tell us about those talks you know you
know seen a series of articles written
about it you know here's how I would
describe it you know the core of Android
everything we do we take a ecosystem
approach we work with partners and
anything we do in connectivity would
have the same attributes to it we've
always tried to push the boundary of
what's next and we have done that with
hardware and software and we do this
with Nexus devices today it's a bit
misunderstood outside as to why we do
Nexus devices right and you know all
innovations in computing happen at the
intersection of hardware and software
and so for you to drive the next
generation you need to do both closely
together this is why we do Nexus devices
and we do it actually in partnership
with our OEMs we choose the OEM to work
with so early on people would always ask
are you competing with the OEM industry
but we never do Nexus at scale right
that's not our intent you know we sell
you know definitely always compared to
the rest of the industry it's a very
small scale but we do that enough scale
to achieve impact you know we have ideas
which you want pushed out into the
ecosystem we do it through Nexus I think
we are at a stage where it's important
to think about hardware software and
connectivity together especially when
you think about form factors like you
need connectivity on your watch you know
if you think about something like
Android auto you need connectivity to do
that possible so we want to be able to
experiment along those lines and so
that's the context in which we are
thinking about is a project we are doing
we don't intend to be a network operator
at scale you know carrier partners are
the ones who will provide services and
even the effort we do here we are
actually working with carrier partners
but you will see as you know announced
it in
coming months but our goal here is to
you know drive a set of innovations
which we think the ecosystem should
adopt and hopefully you know we'll get
traction will again do it at a small
enough scale so that just like Nexus
devices people see what we are doing and
hopefully carry your partner's if they
think ideas are good they can adopt but
that's what this project is about them I
do so wonder though if some your carrier
partners you maybe you're bigger ones
like a verizon or an ATT might look at
this and and wonder whether Google you
know one of their big partners on
Android is also becoming in some way
maybe a small way but in some
significant way a competitor you know
it's for me we have better years of
track record of running Android and how
we do it and you know we keep getting
asked these questions but you know we've
talked with them about all this you know
in fact we are actually working with
some of these carrier partners to do
what we are doing and so I think people
I mean they know what we are doing and
you know Indian in a part partners like
Verizon AT&T t-mobile and Sprint in the
US are you know what powers you know
most of our Android phones and the model
works extremely well for us and so you
know there's no reason for us to
course-correct here is there a
conviction at Google that there needs to
be more innovation and lower prices when
it comes to wireless networks it's more
what trainer completion is a bit
different you know it's for example
thinking through areas like how Wi-Fi
and cellular networks work together and
how can you make that experience
seamless and you know those are all
areas for example if two people are
making phone calls you know if you call
drops maybe you can connect it back
automatically these are all innovations
we are trying to show what's possible
some of the ideas will work out and then
we expect our carrier partners start out
these ideas and so those are the kinds
of things we are trying to do while
bread co Appa Titian and frenemies is
cute in Silicon Valley but if you're
starting to compete with some of your
biggest customers and I AT&T and Verizon
Google's going up or taking an
interesting strategy here if they're
actually be offering
our own service that's right that's
absolutely right and look Google's no
stranger to that right to roll out of
google fiber in the United States I mean
you really can tell that there is a
belief at Google that you know the
carrier's wireless wireline have been
moving too slow that they should be
doing more but of course google also has
to partner with those companies and it's
really interesting to see how Google and
Facebook kind of make nice noises
towards each other I mean I asked sundar
Pichai in his ear vision compatible with
Mark Zuckerberg vision he sees talking
nicely about internet.org facebook
vision but also I think there's a little
subtext of competition also give a
listen to sunders answers leader today
we're going to hear from Mark Zuckerberg
and Facebook more about Internet org and
he expresses really a similar vision
right of bringing connectivity two parts
the world that don't have it how do you
do you feel like your visions are all
that different and you know if not could
the two companies work together look I'm
very excited they're doing it to know
one company can do this it's bringing
connectivity at scale to 4 billion
people and and you know we are happy to
work with them to provide our services
on internet.org so that's exciting for
me having said that I think we are
trying to meets complimentary but what
we are trying to do something different
you know we are trying to add scalable
the backbone so actually provide
physical connectivity at scale across
across the globe and so it is different
as well but I think at a high level
these are complementary and you know I'm
glad companies like Google Facebook and
other carrier partners around the world
you know you need deep resources to make
this happen and some glad we are working
on that
our grad so last week we had at the FCC
make an important decision about
limiting the ability of carriers to
decide what content consumers will get
and now we've got google and facebook
both out there offering new
technological ideas about how to offer
the internet from them so that users
will pick their services first if they
talk about that and is up talked about
that at all when you had to Mobile World
Congress today yeah chuck was asked
about that here's what he had to say
about the idea of flying drones and
balloons and spreading the internet down
to the ground I think that's actually
the fringe of the real work that's going
on the reality is that ninety percent of
people in the world actually already
live within range of a network right and
that's because of the great work that
the industry has already done so well
it's kind of sexy to talk about
satellites and all the stuff the real
work happens here